the other thing that i really adored
from when we spent time together in new
york that you told me about
was a story to do with regrets
from hitch
uh and this is a
we're talking about trade-offs here
right and this has been i wrote a
newsletter about it which i sent to you
and dude it is
it is one of the best
insights
for ameliorating regrets for
understanding that they're an
unavoidable part of our lives
um
you tell that story about yeah
about regrets yes chris richards he said
um
i think he wrote it in his memoir as
well he said uh
he said you have to choose your regrets
um
i mean everyone is going to have regrets
in their life you know
um
i know people who've achieved great
things and achieved
small things
all of them have regrets
[Music]
and yes you you you have to know that
you're going to have regrets
and the question is which ones you can
bear
and which ones you don't think you can
bear
[Music]
let me give you an obvious example
let's say you had a dream always of
starting a shop you know
you've got two options in front of you
really
one is
starting it
and seeing if it works
and the other one is
is not because you fear
that it won't work
you'll fall flat on your ass
um
both both choices have regrets
and
the sort of person you are realized to a
great extent on
which one can i bear
can i bear
not having tried
but at least i didn't fail
more than i can bear
i tried
and i might have failed
either way in this this calculation you
you're you are risking a type of regret
so you have to make the decision
um i have that all the time with writing
um
[Music]
quite a lot of times in my life
i've written things
seriously against my own interests you
know
and
i have this
terrible tearing thing with inside
within me which is
i gotta say the thing i gotta say the
thing i just gotta say the thing don't
say the thing douglas don't say the
thing everyone's going to hate you uh
and i i'm going to say the thing
and
i know that it's because i have two
options in front of me one is one is
haven't it can't give all the details
but it happened not long ago's
politicians um
one is oh well that's that you know i've
broken that
relationship
and i i have that regret now that is a
very big regret actually but um
but on the other hand i would have had
the regret of
i didn't say what i thought
so at least i don't have aragograd
um
but it is it is it is a profound insight
of christopher's because um
you know even freedom which i mentioned
earlier you know is not an unloyed
good it's not like searching for freedom
leads you only to a lack of regrets
um
i mean
my experience of freedom for yourself
can be very costly for others
the thing that it made me realize was
looking back i'd always presumed that
any regret that i had
was due to a sub-optimal decision that
i'd made right and that had i have been
able to go back
and make the right decision
i could have avoided regret entirely i
always thought that regret was a bug
of my decision making not a feature an
inbuilt feature of being a human and as
soon as you realize the fact that look
opportunity cost exists by doing a thing
you're not doing another thing and even
if the thing that you chose to do was
perfectly accurate it was precisely the
right thing you're always going to have
an open loop around what could have
happened had i have done the other thing
so when you're given the choice between
two things
the the the a good way for anybody
that's stuck with the decision
is to think
which of these two choices could i not
bear to live with the regret absolutely
and that is clarified absolutely that
happens i mean i have that thought all
the time i mean all the time
what what could i um
what could i not bear
um as i say for me a very strong one is
speaking my mind
speaking the truth as i see it i
couldn't bear not don't you
i would i find it very hard
um
um
you know an occasion as i say people say
to me
you should be a little bit more
diplomatic you know with this or you
should have been a bit easier on that
person
every elderly friend of mine often
phones me up and says oh that's another
country you can't visit
[Laughter]
unfairly you know
um
but but
yeah so so you you you work out what you
can't
what you
can't bet and
you do realize i mean um
i mean this is a bit self-groundizing
but
there is also a difference in people of
the risk they're willing to take
which is
i don't overemphasize myself because i'm
a writer not a soldier
or a fireman or a policeman
but
i think there are
there are prices you pay
for throwing yourself against the world
and um
you have to decide whether you want to
pay them or not
most people go along with whatever
they're meant to go along with
wherever they are
and the certain type of person doesn't
and
generally speaking i think i tend to be
the sort of person who doesn't
and
that comes with a considerable
benefits in my case freedom a certain
degree of success and so on
but it comes with a certain cost
i mean one of the costs is
um you always feel a certain sense of
isolation you know
uh
not to say loneliness i don't feel like
i'm not lonely in any personal or
ideological sense but
but it's inevitable that if you don't go
along with the precepts
you're going to have a sort of
isolation
um
but then
even that i mean that you and then you
test that all the time
can i bear that
and
some of the time the answer will be no i
can't
other times it'll be
yeah that's fine what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace